for step 3 we must
find the roots remember, this is the variable.
And we want to know what this will be equal to.
so we just solve for Lambda and
we will get
two
lambdas
eigenvalue 1 eigenvalue 2
Those are your two eigenvalues.
Okay.
So to find the roots of the characteristic polymers to find
the eigenvalues now that we have the eigenvalues we can go ahead and find the
eigenvector for our Matrix.
So step 4 would be.
to Now find the eigen
vectors so
we have
this expression
so we want
This equation a Lambda equals
B. I don't I I don't think even I
can see it but this is supposed to be the vector. It's slightly.
more dense
and those are the eigenvalues.
It's not that clear just let's keep that in
mind. Okay, so a is going to be a matrix B is
going to be a vector and this is the eigenvector.
For emphasis. These are the eigenvalues.
These must go in there.
Okay. So how do we find the eigenvectors? We
do this we take our original Matrix?
a
And we multiplied by.
a vector with unknown quantities
step one except two
this will then turn it into a system of
equations.
system of linear equations right because none of these
Are they're all I mean these values are raised
to the power one.
And this will be cool to the vector.
0 0
so we want
to find the values for x
that will make this matrix multiplication. Give
us a vector zero zero.
Now, what does this if we were to convert this
into a matrix? What we what what would we get?
We would get the following system of equations.
to want to just so we actually want
a minus 1 Lambda
a minus 1 Lambda. So we want this Matrix multiplied
by the eigenvector.
So this should become.
times
the vector Lambda
okay, because here we
Took the determinant of a minus Lambda and
the idea. Well, this is it. So
same thing we've done up here.
First we took the determinant of this Matrix.
now we are taking the
now we're solving for.
the eigenvector
of this Matrix
So this Matrix actually become.
Two two one three, so
to find the wagon Vector must
find the actor for specific eigenvalue.
So I will denote.
these as sub 1 and sub 2
these are the two Roots we found.
So let's first solve for let me
make them. Let me make this two and make this one because I want to
follow the own sequence I have here. Anyway, this is
the first route. This is the second root.
Okay, so we're gonna find the actor eigenvectors for
lamb this up one.
Which means that we must evaluate this
Matrix so 2 minus.
One will make this.
one
then this Remains Two.
This remains 1 and 3 minus 1 is just 2.
So this becomes 2.
Okay, so this after we plug
in one for these?
Variables evaluate the expressions and evaluate
these differences.
And we will get this Matrix. We turn
this into a system of a linear equations. We will get
the following
two equations we will have
if you remember from our last session, we eliminated one of these so
we can just
Take one of them.
and solve for x sub 1
and x sub 2
so x sub 1
negative 2 x sub 2 if we
do the algebra, we'll become one.
Okay, so, you know, you know the whole story.
moving X up to another side
and then moving except one other side we get these two roots.
So we don't need to have this repetition we can just keep one of those systems since the
identical.
and solving or x sub
1 and x sub 2
Now that we have x sub 1 and x sub 2 we will be know
the components of the eigenvector.
So we know we can plug in these numbers we can plug in minus 2
or minus 1.
in here
Now here, we also need something called a basis.
So we need the eigenvector for
the first eigenvalid and the eigenvector of the second eigenvalue to
put them together inside a matrix because we're
not just solving for the eigenvectors. We're actually trying
to get to diagonalization. So we're not quite done yet.
which is why I will create a
Vector here and we will use V
sub 1 so V sub 1 is
going to be
the vector
with the roots we have just found.
We will put this eigenvector and the second
one inside.
A matrix so these will become the columns.
of The Matrix